bonsoir à tous et même bonjour Johnny
Hallyday
on va être bien ici non
on va parler du pastis on va avoir un
live en fin d'émission et puis Marseille
bébé c'est la vie à tout de suite à la
réunion le barbecue est une institution
il fait partie de la culture locale et
il a ses propres codes
que chez les hommes
pas vrai
pendant que les femmes se reposent voilà
exactement mais elle va faire la salade
un truc d'homme donc les barbecues de
l'été vont-ils devoir se faire sans
Ricard ce qui est sur c'est que vous
n'en trouvez plus dans vos centres
Leclerc c'est pourtant le deuxième
produit le plus vendu en grande surface
mais le géant de la distribution et le
groupe Père Noël car ne parviennent pas
s'entendre sur les prix et ce sont les
clients qui en pâtissent yamspenser au
Leclerc de la colle sur loupe un seul
article permet rayon alors quand il va
prendre la nouvelle il y a plus de 51
ans j'ai très peur je suis un gros
consommateur de Ricard et ça me fait
énormément peur on rappelle que l'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé sa
consommation augmente le temps de
réaction diminue les réflexes perturbes
la coordination des mouvements bref
l'alcool vous transforme en tennisman
français un golfeur pas vraiment à la
fête le joueur pro canadien d'amadouine
est venu sur le green célébrer la
victoire de son compatriote Nick Taylor
avec une bouteille de champagne mais un
agent de sécurité un peu trop aidé n'a
pas apprécié cette intrusion pétillante
résultat un plaquage un peu brutal
a réagi avec humour sur Twitter en
demandant d'exposer cette action qui
fait le tour de la toile au Louvre et là
vous avez carrément le plus grand écran
du monde le plus grand écran du monde
fait quatre étages de haut plus de 100 m
de long en plus c'est un écran qui
marche dans les deux sens c'est à dire
qu'on peut regarder à l'intérieur de
l'écran comme à l'extérieur c'est un
écran double face c'est assez incroyable
donc on prend une claque monumentale
quand on vient à l'intérieur et
dites-moi regardez vraiment l'ambiance
du stade c'est ce qui change tout bah
oui comment
vous êtes Baptiste un grand supporteur
de
l'ombre
j'ai pas de scoop mais je vais essayer
de pousser vous rendez compte c'est
c'est 2 secondes les spots dans lequel
on est dire que ces deux secondes et ça
devient
Emmanuel Macron
mais je ne peux pas tout faire pour ça
62 et 63 sont tombés tout à l'heure avec
l'adoption du numéro je sais plus quel
moment j'ai un rapporteur
qui leur faute c'est une cargaison
entière
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur
le
madame la Présidente de la Commission
c'est lamentable madame c'est lamentable
l'essentiel est invisible pour les yeux
on ne voit bien qu'avec le cœur
Saint-Exupéry c'est celui-là mais au
moment de faire le tatouage impossible
de retrouver cette phrase et du coup je
suis partie dans une autre phrase qui du
coup sur le coup m'inspirait vachement
je me suis dit waouh ça ressemble bien
c'est pas mal argent trop cher ou pourvu
qu'elle soit douce le point commun je
vais prendre le point commun il y a un
point commun
entre pourvu qu'elle soit douce et
argent trop cher moi je vois un point
commun immédiat argent trop cher et
pourvu qu'elle soit douce c'est Bruno Le
Maire c'est notre ministre finance et
fesses quoi c'est nouveau
le nouveau truc quoi regardez voilà
[Musique]
ferme les yeux mais c'est quoi
ferme les yeux et tu verras
[Musique]
mon Dieu que les hommes sont bêtes que
les hommes sont bêtes
[Musique]
[Rires]
nous sommes vraiment très très inquiets
pour nos amis d'en face
godemichet des sextoys quand je pense à
faire dans de l'urine brune je bande ça
ne fougère
et j'ai du retour sur le plateau
bon il faut vraiment les sortir de là
zigounette le zizi tripote des godes je
bande aussi
c'est news c'était vraiment mieux avant
alors les chéris il y a une darka j'ai
quand même un faux Canal+ votre demande
de rendez-vous a été prise en compte par
notre service
c'est une affaire qui devrait la
chronique dans les cas au four les
buvettes et autres lieux de rencontre de
la ville d'Obala l'un des points de
vente des billets bouillis haricots les
plus populaires du centre-ville a été
scellé ce 4 juin par les forces de
maintien de l'ordre pour pratique de
sorcellerie et empoisonnement le nommé
lui Bernard dit qui âgé de 47 ans a été
surpris en train de déféquer à
l'intérieur de son box où il a
l'habitude de pétrir la pâte de ses
beignets on l'utilise pour que les
frites ou encore les beignets l'huile de
friture est un ingrédient essentiel en
cuisine mais désormais elle est aussi la
cible de voleurs des groupes criminels
internationaux très organisés qui volent
cette matière grasse usagée pour la
revendre à prix d'or en quête sur un
nouveau trafic qui explose en France
les populations sous le choc n'en
reviennent pas d'avoir consommé des
beignets caca pendant des années selon
ses consommateurs outrés le fait de
déféquer dans son atelier de beignets
renvoie à une pratique de sorcellerie
qui consiste à introduire des selles
dans la farine afin d'attirer
mystiquement le maximum de clients
il y a quelques jours
26000 litres d'huile usagée ont été
retrouvés ici par les gendarmes une
découverte qui a permis de démanteler un
trafic très organisé l'huile était
d'abord volé dans des fast-foods de
cette région par des hommes d'origine
bulgare avant d'être envoyé au Pays-Bas
pour être transformé en biocarburant une
organisation criminelle internationale y
a-t-il des protéines dans les Benny caca
je vous demande
bien sûr
Merci à VOUS bravo et bonne nuit
si vous pouvez s'arrêter maintenant on a
déjà vécu beaucoup de choses ensemble on
pourrait s'en satisfaire